so this is actually my first crew do
conference talk every other talk I've
given has been internal or to small
meetups or just groups of friends so
this is actually kind of exciting for me
thank you thank you so I am a developer
advocate with the Google Chrome team and
my explicit focus is Chrome extensions
and the the Chrome Web Store so today
I'd like to talk to you a bit about how
Chrome is trying to evolve the
extensions platform in order to make it
more secure stable and reliable friend
users so the high-level overview of what
I'm going to be talking about is a broad
history of an abbreviated history of
browser extensions and custom is a
customized ability in the browser
Chrome's approach to extensions and
finally what is changing in manifest v3
so onto the browser history browser
history is very long very complicated
there's a ton of different stuff so I'm
gonna be giving a vastly oversimplified
history here and if you're expecting
something exciting here don't be because
it is literally these bullet points so
first up we have Netscape Navigator
Internet Explorer and then Firefox v1
each of these kind of introduces a new
concept to browser extension and
customization and obviously finally
Chrome with its own special take so
Netscape Navigator wait before I go on
one of my favorite things about this
slide is the the animation in the
Navigator logo I totally forgot it's
been long enough that but when I was
doing research for this and looking into
the history of browsers I forgot how
common these kind of throb animations
were and it's an artifact of web history
that I kind of miss anyway Netscape
Navigator was the first browser that
allowed third-party developers to modify
what the browser could do post
installation after it was actually on
the user's machine and they did this
through the introduction of a NPAPI or
Netscape plug-in application programming
interface
NPAPI was cool because it allowed
third-party developers to register new
content types that the browser could
display and the user could interact with
so this was originally introduced
specifically for Java applets but later
on folks like Mozilla used this
capability to add the ability to for
application PDF work to display PDFs in
a browser so this capability was reverse
engineer able and ultimately extendable
by third other third parties but one of
the disadvantages of this approach is
that fundamentally they didn't really
have a security model this was just a
some native code running in the browser
executed in the browser's process and it
had the same capabilities the threat
model at the time was very different
than we have today so that wasn't too
much of a concern but it was something
to be aware of the most practical side
effect of this is if you had an unstable
plugin let's say maybe it was something
like a PDF displayer it might crash your
browser unexpectedly that was pretty not
great as an end user experience the next
major phase we have here is internet
explorer floor Internet Explorer
introduced the first this was the first
time a a browser allowed third parties
to actually modify the browser's
behavior rather than just the the
content that it could display and before
I go on again logo stuff this in my head
is what I think of when I think of
Internet Explorer 4 it turns out this is
actually like the eye 6 and 7 logo in
loading animation ie 4 actually had this
modern style logo which I find kind of
funny that we started here and then
moved away and went skeuomorphic and
then came back to this super reduced
minimal thing anyway none of that's
important so one of the capabilities
that they introduced from 94 was this
shortcuts menu or context menu when you
right-click you were able to go to a
menu and take an action that would be
invoked in your extension
this was a nice bit of functionality but
not I don't know
the end-all-be-all internet explorer
also introduced Explorer VARs or in what
some modern browsers call sidebars so
this is persistent content that frames
the web UI that you're interacting with
next up we have toolbars and you can see
Google is one of the many providers of
toolbars this would typically be things
like overriding your search provider
adding customization - I don't know
common behaviors that you might have or
maybe even tabs or uh what do they call
bookmarks of course this could be pretty
terrible and you ended up with stuff
like this where of course Google is a
contributor to this mess now one of the
reasons that we ended up in this
situation is that it in order to install
an extension you had to execute an
installer and that would drop a binary
in your file system and that would
register you would add a registry
interest entry so that I would know
where to look - in order to load your
extension which made it kind of hard for
non tech savvy users to get rid of stuff
and with the capabilities of running in
a binary it also made it so extension
developers could make some bad
not-so-great
user interface decisions that made it
hard to get rid of there their tools
their tools and finally the third major
or fourth major thing that Internet
Explorer introduced was this concept of
browser helper objects or be a chose by
and large the entire extension feature
is commonly referred to as be a chose or
in extension was commonly referred to as
a Pho even though the first things
shortcuts Explorer VARs and toolbars
could be provided without a BHO that's
kind of an implementation detail but
whatever so the way the system worked is
you would compile a native dll that used
a kind of standardized comm interface in
order to communicate with
Internet Explorer and BA chose could
then have this full set of native
capabilities and file system access and
you know potentially owning a user's
machine not not the best security
capabilities anyway this one that we're
looking at right now the web accessible
web accessibility toolbar produced by
Vision Australia it would let you do
things like preview a grayscale mode or
see what your web experience would be
like with for color Brian blind users or
expose in a visual way the accessibility
tree it was actually a pretty cool
extension that helped a lot of
developers Firefox is kind of the next
major step in the customization of
browser extensions in that this was the
first time well there were a couple of
interesting first with Firefox predating
Firefox is a application suite that was
produced by Mozilla called Mozilla
application suite clever name they they
basically had an email client in an RSS
reader and a web browser in this package
and I think a calendar - of all of this
package of tools that a user can use to
you know accomplish their day to day
native work on their desktop what was
really cool about this is they used an
user interface language called Zul XML
user interface language and it could be
scripted or programmed scripted with
JavaScript or programmed with xpcom
which is a cross-platform component
object model basically the same thing as
the com model that ie was using except
now it's cross platform and you can do
more languages rather than just the
specific things that would compile to
the common interface later on oh right I
was talking about Mozilla application
suite that's also known as sea monkey if
you might have heard that term sea
monkey was interesting because the
entire thing was scriptable using Zul
and one of these languages
so they were using web technologies to
build an entire web browser an
application suite what happened with
Firefox is they took those capabilities
and formalized them and expose them as
the extension platform so it was
possible in to use web technologies to
build the web browser it was possible to
use web technologies to customize the
web browser they also tried to do some
sandboxing here to limit the nefarious
things that extensions could do but
ultimately it wasn't that hard to get
full control of the browser with xpcom
and therefore do terrible things with to
the user's machine part of what was
novel with Firefox here though is they
introduced for the first time the
ability to install extensions from the
web so this is a whole interesting
potential vector for a new class of
attacks and again like the previous ones
this is the the app the X become DLL
that is being loaded in the browser is
arbitrary binary so you again you could
do some pretty terrible stuff so inter
chrome extensions chrome extensions were
introduced in chrome 4.0 which is very
very early on I think maybe a year or
two after chrome was first released the
main the goals are listed here the of
the Chrome extension platform but the
main thing I want to call out is that
chrome is Webby it is stable and our
Chrome extensions are Webby stable and
secure so it's webby in that they're
built with web technologies HTML
Javascript and CSS it's stable in that a
Fault in the extension isn't going to
bring down the whole browser process the
worst case is the unstable extension
will take itself down and you know it'll
die on its own in the corner and it's
secure in that it adopts the web
security model with some additional
modifications specific to the extension
platform in order to increase the
security of the additional capabilities
that are exposed there this is a
fundamental shift from how everything I
guess pre Firefox Firefox had a little
bit of ability to do this but
they were still something different they
were using special technologies to build
the extensions platform where Chrome
extensions are all just web technologies
with some additional api's and I wanted
to call out it this breaks away from
native api's with the small Astra that
content displaying capabilities like we
originally discussed with Netscape it
still supports it still supported NPAPI
and some additional Chrome specific
stuff Knakal and pinochle but those are
going away in favor of wasm so let's
pretend they don't exist I only care
about extensions anywhere so moving on
no extension platform no software
platform is perfect so in the
intervening years between the original
release of extensions and the current
platform as we know it today we started
to see some patterns in the extension
ecosystem of both abuse and user error
on the part of developers where
developers would do things that weren't
in their best interest they would have
accidental vulnerabilities so in order
to address some of those we introduced
some stuff like a web accessible
resources field in your manifest JSON oh
I just realized I didn't actually go
over all the contents of a Chrome
extension we'll get into some details
later
so the main entry point of a Chrome
extension is manifest.json there's a
JSON file that defines the name of your
extension the current version what files
to run in the background what files to
inject into the page etc in manifest v2
it introduced this web accessible
resources so only resources that you
want to expose to the web context or
other places would actually appear or be
accessible and this was addressing a
common attack vector where people were
able to use signals that are leaked by
the extension in order to figure out
which extension is running and if
knowing the exploits available on that
extension could then
hook in and didn't do bad things to the
user
anything else I wanted to cover in that
nah again no platform is perfect there
were some issues here even as we tried
to plug some of these issues are some of
the exploits that existed one of which
was that if an extension in its
background page loaded an iframe of a
third-party website that third-party
website could use browser exploits to
gain control of the extension and
therefore have elevated privileges to do
bad things to the user the way that the
chrome team addressed this was by
separating the iframe process from the
extension process so they no longer
share the same memory and can't be
directly accessed more broadly site
isolation is something the extension
team and chrome team are very concerned
about we removed the ability to perform
inline installation so previously it was
possible to visit some website let's say
AFRICOM and to click the install Chrome
extension button and then suddenly you
would have the buffer extension
installed in your web browser of course
a malicious actor could have buffer with
three FS rather than to directly clone
their website clone their extension and
then add a little bit of more code that
allowed them to exploit the user and the
end user would be none the wiser
the end user thinks they're doing
everything correctly it appears that
they're doing everything correctly but
unfortunately they've just given
somebody else the keys to the kingdom
the final thing that I want to call out
in improvements that we've made to the
current extension platform is changing
it so that extensions that are loaded in
the browser the user has more control
over when and how they run so right here
I'm interacting with the posit google
dictionary extension which lets you
define terms on a page and I know that I
work with some sensitive data so I don't
want to expose every page that I visit
to it I only want to say expose
google.com in that case I can
right-click the extension go to this can
read and change data cite data and
then select the specific sites where I
want the extension to run or only run
the extension in response to clicking
the extensions browser action the icon
in the toolbar
the ultimate goal here is that we're
giving users more control this change
was made in chrome 70 and in the future
we're planning to change it so by
default when you install an extension it
will not default to all sites that will
default to the most limited set of
capabilities now I talked about some of
the things that we've done to address
limitations of manifest v2 but there are
other things that we can't quite address
here for one there's not enough focus on
usability when the chrome team designed
the extension interaction patterns the
the platform there was a fundamental
assumption about how users interact with
install prompts and I think in the
assumption that people read all the
words and understand them and make
informed decisions that's not always
true unfortunately I think in the
intervening years we've seen that users
don't quite understand what read and
modify all site data means for example
and that's an extremely common thing
because all URLs is extremely common in
the extension ecosystem the all URLs
permission allows an extension to eject
content scripts on any site that you
visit and in some cases to kind of
supercharge other api's that the browser
exposes so the tabs API for example
actually tabs is a bad example ignore
that pretend I didn't say that but in
general all URLs is too common it is
very powerful permission it is
unfortunately currently the only way to
do some things like passively inject UI
into a page and when it's too common
that means that we can't detect
anomalous use of this permission because
everybody requests it one of the major
things that has been in the news and the
recently is that remote code injection
in an extension is currently allowed and
it's kind of a problem but it's a
problem that we don't think we can
address on the manifest v2 platform
because it breaks some fundamental
assumptions about how extensions work so
that's why it's going into this this
platform version bump if effectively if
a code if an extension loads code that
isn't bundled in the extensions
executable then it can do anything at
any time and we can't know about it or
react to it very well in fact the thing
that it does today might not be the same
thing as it does tomorrow or the thing
that it does for me might be the same as
it does for you which is I think a
pretty bad world to be in I mentioned
this a bit in discussion of all URLs
powerful api's are currently your only
option for a lot of capabilities that is
for a content blocker say in order to
allow a content blocker to block a
website I have to give that that content
blocker access to the websites that I
want to block which means that it could
potentially perform who-knows-what
actions on those sites without my
knowledge or consent this is more of a
chrome issue but extensions can tank
performance and in tank it in a way
that's not terribly obvious to the
end-user so by a developer not coding an
extension in a performant way they can
unintentionally make the entire browser
experience significantly worse and
finally users don't have enough control
over their experience we address some of
this or now trying to work through this
with the upcoming change I mentioned to
default to restricting all URLs to only
unclick but that that again is going to
require a version font in order to
actually tackle so I think it's fair to
say that we are not in a situation that
we want to be that the extension
platform is more vulnerable kind of by
design than it should be and to that end
we're introducing manifest weak
which will shift some of these basic
assumptions about how the platform works
so the broad strokes the goals of
manifest v3 are to improve the security
privacy and performance of the Chrome
extensions platform for security we want
to improve the security guarantees that
is we want to be able to say with
confidence that it is significantly
harder or impossible for a malicious
site or extension to gain control of
these privileged execution environments
and by extension to increase end-user
trust that when they extol in an
extension it isn't going to do anything
harmful to them without their without
their direct involvement and that they
can easily remove an extension and it
won't cause any lasting harm for privacy
we want users to have more control over
their experience so for privacy we we
want the user to have more control over
what sites and extension is executing on
and part of that is going to be a shift
in or trying to encourage developers to
shift how they expect their extensions
to run rather than passively running all
the time we want extensions to move to a
model where they're running in response
to user action so the user is ultimately
the one that's in control and for
performance extensions we want
extensions to be performed by default we
want developers to fall into a pit of
success where even if they don't know
what they're doing and they do some
anti-patterns worst case scenario that
things will kind of work out for them
anyway and by extension reducing the
amount of resources that an extension is
using over over the course of its life
so at this point I want to get a bit
into the specifics of some of these
changes runtime host permissions that is
the ability to inject script into a site
we want to as I said move to clicked by
default we have a permissions in the
Chrome extension platform called active
tab that
browser can or an extension can
currently choose to opt into active tab
style permissions where when somebody
clicks a browser action or hits a global
keyboard shortcut or hits the omnibox
shortcut that they've read in a store
Tory triggers the context menu entry
those are the four ways that you can get
active tab only then does the extension
have the ability to run and for
extensions that do require or need to
passively inject there will be a way to
do that but it isn't going to be the
primary way that most extensions are
expected to operate this is challenging
though because it is a shift in the
extension architecture it will require
developers to make it a shift in their
architecture in order to be more evented
and more contextual so again in the
future when you click the extension will
be the default option at install time
they're still working on the UI for this
but at install time it will have an
option it will present the user with an
option that says when you click the
extension and they will have a way of
changing that to to automatically run on
all sites or on specific sites and then
developers will also have a way of
checking their current permissions and
then re prompting the user if they don't
have enough if they can't do their job
basically another significant change
that we're making is replacing the web
request block the blocking version of
the web request API with a new API
called declarative net request for the
most part most of the capabilities of
declarative net request api don't
actually require host permissions so
again we're limiting the potential
vulnerabilities and attack vectors by
just giving extensions less right out of
the gate but fundamentally web request
is more capable because it's a
imperative API you can literally what
write whatever code you want and it will
do it whereas the declarative net
request API it's declarative so there's
a limited set of capabilities that you
can actually execute one of the benefits
to this from a performance point of view
is we're getting extensions out of the
web request flow which means we can
heavily optimize how
how network requests are processed by
extensions currently it takes several
process hops in order for an extension
to even get notified that that a request
is being made and then they have to
exceed some logic and then pass it back
to Chrome which takes a couple more
process hops all of this is potentially
you know depending on the implementation
details potentially all able to be
executed on the network thread meaning
there's no additional hops that just
happens immediately as soon as chrome
executes side so a quick example I'm
gonna say I have been known to spend too
much time on Facebook so when I'm at
work I just don't want it to be
available at all so I'm going to have a
simple extension here that requires the
web request API the request blocking API
and access to facebook.com so this is
the manifest.json i mentioned earlier
and you can see I have a background
script that I'm going to passively load
and have running my background script is
going to receive a details object or a
request object that contains details
about the request so this is kind of the
passive data that's being exposed to the
extension so any in in this simple
example anytime I see a request going to
facebook.com I'm gonna return a object
that says cancel so the can't request
will be blocked and otherwise don't do
any special modification and that's the
super simple extension the way this
would look in the declarative net
requests world is we replace all those
permissions with a simple one
declarative net request with no
additional host permissions no
additional ability to inject content and
we're we now have a rules JSON which
will define the network request
modification rules that Chrome will
execute our rules list is pretty simple
all we're gonna do is if we see a
request for facebook.com we're gonna
take the action block that's it
another major change that is happening
in chrome manifest v3 is the migration
from background pages to serviceworkers
so if you're not familiar with the exten
and platform the way it currently works
is if you have when you create an
extension one of the core pieces that
you have is a background page or
background script which has a page
environment so you you're literally
running an entire web page headless it
just doesn't render anything which means
that you have the full capabilities of
the web in terms of being able to place
a audio or being able to use event
propagation natively in your background
page in the future we're moving to
service workers which are web technology
that's emerging kind of under the
progressive Web App banner and it allows
you to have a more ephemeral execution
environment where your service worker
gets woken up in response to events it
has some time that it can execute and
then when it's no longer doing anything
it just gets terminated and then frees
up the resources so this service worker
environment is extremely similar to the
current event page system you can have
today in manifest v2 you can have two
types of background pages you can have a
persistent page which lives forever or
you can have an event page which is only
woken up in response to events in
general this is kind of a pattern of
chrome trying to provide more performant
options but most people fall back on the
less performant version so event pages
have not been as well adopted as we
would like part of the move to service
workers is just cleaning up to hit use a
standardized use the standards that the
web platform exposes since Chrome
extensions are webby we want to use the
web as our default environment with only
the modifications required to enable
extensions so some of the challenges
that this move is going to present to
developers is they don't have access to
dom with all of the capabilities that
involves it requires a more event based
approach to application development
which you may or may not currently be
doing and given that you no longer have
a persistent global environment you can
no longer have state sitting there
passively exposed so let's take a look
at a couple of examples i am i have a
simple
X I have a simple extension here that
basically is just gonna pass a message
to the content script that will display
somebody's name I think in this these
code samples I left out the content
script because it's not that important
but basically it just has a message
handler that receives a name and then
logs it nothing fancy
so here the extension currently has
persistent persistent true if you don't
explicitly specify persistent false it
is by default true and then our
background script basically if we get a
message that that sets the user's name
then we'll set the global name variable
to whatever them name is that we
received and then when you click the
browser action button the icon in your
the Chrome window then we will send the
name to the the content script that's
all that's happening here it's not
terribly fancy the problem that we're
gonna have with this in the migration to
manifest b3 is we're not gonna have
global state anymore so in order to work
around that we need to tweak it a little
bit here we're explicitly calling out
that persistent is false so now we're
using an event page and rather than
having a global variable that we're
reading and writing we're using chrome
storage sync to set the user's name when
they pass it in and we're using criminal
storage that same tacit to retrieve the
user's name when when we want to send
the message to the background page so
this is basically shifting from global
state sort in JavaScript to state stored
in a persistent place the next step in
the migration is going to be changing
from an event page to a serviceworker so
here we have a script it's a single
person a background page or a single non
persistent background page here we're
explicitly declaring a serviceworker and
it's worth noting here that in the
introduction of serviceworkers you will
be able to use service workers with
manifest v2 this is intended to help
developers migrate from the current
platform to the the new version that
we're going to be using
the third and I think final change that
I want to call out is remotely hosted
code as I said we're not going to allow
you to execute code that isn't part of
your extension bundle in the
not-too-distant future one of the
challenges that this is going to prevent
to developers is that it limits the
dynamism that you can have some people
are currently using this to not ill
affect like they're doing good things by
delivering updates very quickly to users
or to a be test and make sure that their
extension is performing as well as it
can in order to adapt to this developers
are essentially going to need to bundle
their third-party code into the art
bundle the resources that they want to
load at runtime bundle that into the
extension and load it from the extension
so here we're doing a simple incredibly
simple thing where we have a content
script that is just going to inject
jQuery onto the page and as you could
see we're loading jQuery from the
official jQuery website all this content
script does is create an element assign
the appropriate attributes and then
append it to the parent document in the
new world we're going to need to
explicitly expose the jQuery library
using web accessible resources and we're
bundling the library with our extension
and then when we want to inject it we
just use chrome runtime get URL to
retrieve a a URL in order to load the
specific file the rest is basically the
same and with that I just want to
quickly go through the the major changes
again to the extension platform we're
trying to move towards an active tab
style set of permissions so users are in
control of when the extension is running
we're moving away from API is that
leaked data like web requests in order
to make sure that as little information
as being exposed to the extension as
reasonably possible the web requests
change here is the first of many steps
in this direction but I think in future
versions of the
platform and additional changes in
manifest v2 or manifest v3 you can
expect that we're gonna be trying to
tighten up
how and when extensions are running and
what data they're getting access to and
finally we're replacing a weight this
there is a fourth one we're replacing
background pages with service workers
and that's going to have some impact on
how extensions are architected and how
they approach the job that they're doing
and finally we're removing the ability
to run remotely hosted code through a
combination of platform API level
changes and chrome Chrome Web Store
policy changes if you are interested in
continuing to dig into the extension
ecosystem I'd recommend checking out the
Google Chrome or Chrome extensions
google group and also checking out the
manifest v3 design document the design
document is public like almost all
chrome design documents and the
intention is to this is the launching
off point this isn't a definitive
document but it's the starting point
from which the team is starting to work
to actually implement these features
finally if you have any feedback on this
stuff as the extensions developer
advocate
I am extremely interested in it so
please tell me so I can help make the
extensions platform as good as possible
for you and for everyone else
again the chromium extension Google
group or if you want to reach out to me
directly
I'm dot proto on Twitter and you can
also schedule office hours to do a one
on one video based session or phone call
with me using the bitly link here and
that is it thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]